guten Abend zusammen willkommen zu ZDF
heute live russland hat die Ukraine in
den vergangenen Wochen mit den wohl
schwersten Angriffen seit Beginn des
Krieges überzogen also seit fast zwei
Jahren schauen wir uns die aktuelle
Situation im Osten an der Front
an dort gibt es heftige Gefechte aber
wenig Bewegung in der seit Monaten
umkämpften Stadt adivka und hier bei
kupjansk wo Putins Armee immer mehr
Panzer und Soldaten verliert Ziel der
russischen Angriffe in der Region krakiv
ist es offenbar verlorene Gebiete
östlich des oskiillusses und kupjansk
selbst einzunehmen westliche
Militärbeobachter warnen davor dass
Moskau hier Truppen sammelt um die
Angriffe noch einmal zu
verstärken stellt sich die Frage wie es
in den kommenden Wochen und Monaten
weitergeht scheitert Putins
Winteroffensive darüber wollen wir
sprechen mit dem Militärexperten
Christian Mölling er ist
stellvertretender Direktor des
Forschungsinstituts bei der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik und
Leiter des Zentrums für Sicherheit und
Verteidigung wir werden gleich unsere
Reporterin Alisa jung in Kiev erreichen
sie wird uns Ihre Eindrücke live aus der
Ukraine schildern und wir gehen nach
Brüssel zu unserem Korrespondenten Ulf
Röller er hat für uns das Treffen des
natoukraine Rats beobachtet da ging es
auf diplomatenebene um weitere
Militärhilfen schickt uns eure Fragen
und eure Kommentare schreibt sie einfach
in die Chats oder schickt uns eine mail
ich gebe sie dann gerne an unsere Gäste
weiter wir beginnen jetzt mit dem
Militärexperten Christian möling guten
Abend hallo guten Abend Herr Mölling wie
schätzen Sie die aktuelle Situation an
der Front ein na ich glaube wir dürfen
uns auf keinen Fall in einer Art von von
Ruhe wiegen weder durch die Annahme dass
diese Offensive scheitert das ist ja die
das eine was jetzt sozusagen die der die
neue Diskussion ist oder auf der anderen
Seite Leute die sagen wir hätten es mit
einem Pat zu tun insbesondere mit von
einer Pats Situation kann man nicht
sprechen denn
der Begriff des Pats liicht nahe dass
wir am Ende eines Spiels werden wie
viele Züge sowohl Russland als auch die
Ukraine noch machen können in diesen in
den kommenden Monaten das wird sich
zeigen hängt aber im Wesentlichen von
der Hilfe des Westens ab und auf der
anderen Seite von der Hilfe die Russland
von seinen Partnern also im Iran und
auch Nordkorea bekommt auf diese Hilfen
sowohl für die eine als auch für die
andere Seite werden wir später noch
eingehen es gibt direkt aus dem Chat
Fragen von Mario was muss passieren dass
die aktuelle russische Druckphase
überwunden und eine neue Phase des
Krieges eingeleitet wird also es gibt ja
Stimmen die sagen dass SE Russland seine
Kräfte für den Moment ausgereizt hat
sehen Sie da Hinweise
natürlich gibt's immer wieder Hinweise
die darauf hindeuten aber wir sehen ja
gleichzeitig auch dass Russland äh seine
Kapazitäten was die materielle
Durchhaltefähigkeit also die Industrie
angeht gestärkt hat und wir gehen
zurzeit auch davon aus dass Russland im
Zweifelsfalle kein Problem hat oder
weniger Probleme hat neue Soldaten zu
gewinnen auch da ist Russland kreativ
gewesen ich glaube der größte Fehler den
wir machen können ist zu glauben dass
das was gestern und vorgestern in der
letzten Woche Stand der Dinge gewesen
ist dass das morgen und übermorgen auch
so ist der Krieg hat immer wieder
Überraschungen gezeigt gute oder
schlechte für für die Ukraine m und ich
glaube darauf sollte man nicht vertrauen
das was die Ukraine braucht und das
wissen wir vom ersten Tage an ist
Unterstützung der Eindruck des ersten
Kriegsjahres dass die Ukraine ganz
leicht ganz viel Gelände zurückgewinnen
kann ist sicherlich ein Ausdruck davon
gewesen oder ein Startpunkt gewesen vor
dem jetzt Enttäuschung sich breit macht
aber es gehört immer wieder mit dazu
dass diese Enttäuschung auch zum Teil zu
einem großen Teil durch den Westen
selber produziert ist denn er ist nicht
nur Beobachter er ist aktiver Akteur
denn er unterstützt die Ukraine und das
was wir in den letzten sech Monaten
nicht geliefert haben hat die Situation
jetzt in der Ukraine mitbestimmt es gibt
noch eine zweite Frage aus dem Chat
könnte es möglicherweise die Absicht der
Ukraine bzw des Westens sein dass die
Ukraine absichtlich in einer defensiven
Position verbleibt um die russischen
Streitkräfte zu
erschöpfen ich glaube da muss man sehr
stark unterscheiden zwischen einer eher
taktischen Perspektive was passiert da
gerade vor Ort natürlich hat die Ukraine
gerade gar keine Kräfte um überhaupt in
irgendeine Offensive zu gehen das hat ja
auch was mit dem Gelände zu tun in der
Situation der man ist aber vor allen
Dingen auch mit der Versorgung mit
Munition und der Ausbildung dem
Ausbildungsstand der eigenen Truppen da
ist es zurzeit sicherlich sinnvolle für
die Ukraine in der Defensive zu bleiben
und dann eben in der Tat die russischen
Angriffe zurückzuschlagen das ist
einfacher aber hierfür da sind ja in den
letzten Tagen auch Zahlen veröffentlicht
worden fehlt der Ukraine tatsächlich
effektiv mehr artiller runition um die
eigenen Leute auch zu schützen um eben
diese Angriffe sicher zurückzuschlagen
aus der Distanz und nicht durch eigene
infanteriekräfte möglicherweise
zurückzuschlagen und da sind die
Handlungsoptionen tatsächlich geringer
geworden für die Ukraine sie hat keine
andere Wahl als sich zu verteidigen denn
wenn sie aufgeben würde würde das den
Tod für viele andere Ukrainer bedeuten
nicht nur die Aufgabe von Land sondern
vor allening von Menschen aber die
Möglichkeiten die wir der Ukraine geben
die sind radikal gesunken wir werden
gleich noch mal intensiver über Waffen
und Munitionsmangel sprechen und wollen
uns jetzt ein Bild direkt aus der
Ukraine machen vielen Dank Herr Mölling
für den Moment sie bleiben weiter bei
uns wir sprechen gleich
weiter und jetzt schauen wir direkt in
die Ukraine da ist die ostukrainische
Großstadt hakiv am Montag aus der L Luft
angegriffen worden es soll mindestens
vier Treffer gegeben haben eine Fabrik
und eine Bildungseinrichtung sein
beschädigt worden heißt es nach den
schweren Luftangriffen rund um den
Jahreswechsel war es das dritte derart
schwere Bombardement bin weniger Tage im
Fokus waren Orte die weniger stark von
der Flugabwehr geschützt
sind und wir sprechen jetzt
mit zuerst mit unserer Reporterin Alisa
jung da ist sie wieder in Kiev hallo
Alisa beschreib uns die aktuelle
Situation
bitte die Situation in der Ukraine
stellt sich so da dass es also immer
wieder raketenalarm gibt in
unterschiedlichen Städten auch in der
Hauptstadt in Kiev es kann ruhigen es
können ruhige Nächte sein es können aber
auch wirklich Nächte mit immer wieder
Alarm sein wie ist so ein Alarm wie ist
der dann einzuschätzen es wird also auch
großflächig im ganzen Land Alarm
ausgelöst wenn ein Flugzeug ein russis
russisches Flugzeug aufsteigt was
potentiell eine hyperschallrakete bei
sich tragen könnte dann heißt es einfach
Alarm für das ganze Land damit alle
Schutz suchen können im besten Falle
natürlich schnellst möglich denn wenn
eine solche Rakete abgeschossen wird
dann bleibt natürlich nicht mehr allzu
viel Zeit insofern gibt es also immer
wieder unruhige Nächte manchmal auch
Verschnaufpausen aber natürlich sorgt
man sich hier davor ob es auch wieder zu
solch heftigen Angriffswellen kommen
könnte wie wir sie gesehen haben in den
letzten zwei Wochen dort wurden
unterschiedlichste Raketentypen Drohnen
eingesetzt und der Sprecher der
Luftverteidigung mit dem ich gesprochen
habe der hat das auch so beschrieben es
fliegt einfach alles gleichzeitig und
aus allen Richtungen und das macht die
Situation natürlich insbesondere auch
für die Luftverteidigung hier in der
Ukraine so herausfordernd du hast es
gerade gesagt du hast heute mit dem
Sprecher der ukrainischen Luftabwehr
sprechen können du warst heute mit einem
mobilen Team der Flugabwehr unterwegs
was hast du da noch mal an Details in
Erfahrung bringen können wie dramatisch
ist die Lage für die
Flugabwehr es gibt also zusätzlich zur
ukrainischen Luftverteidigung auch Teams
die aus Freiwilligen stehen die sich
also zusammengetan haben die sich
koordinieren mit der territorialen
Verteidigung und die dann in solchen
Fällen wenn es zu besonders viel
Beschuss kommt also ausrücken das kann
man sich auch teilweise sogar recht
simpel vorstellen manchmal sind das
einfach nur Pickups Autos mit einer
Ladefläche auf der dann diese mobilen
Teams ausrücken die haben dann auch
manchmal nur automatische Gewehre mit
denen sie tatsächlich Drohnen vom Himmel
holen also zusätzlich zu dieser
professionellen Luftverteidigung der
Ukraine die auch ausgestattet wurde mit
Systemen aus dem Westen wie z.B dem
Patriot System gibt es auch wirklich
diese freiwilligen mobilen Einsatzteams
die dann ausrücken man versucht in
dieser Situation wenn also über 100
verschiedene Raketentypen hier auf
dieses Land auf die Städte niedergehen
das dann zu unterstützen mit diesen
freiwilligen trups aber lasst uns auch
gerne noch mal detailliert auf das
sprechen was ich erfahren konnte von dem
Sprecher der ukrainischen
Luftverteidigung wir schauen auch mal
gemeinsam jetzt in einen Ton von ihm
rein und dann werde ich das Ganze noch
mal ein bisschen einordnen sehr
gerne wenn der Feind mit einer großen
Anzahl von Raketen und Drohnen angreift
ist es sicherlich sein Ziel unser
Luftverteidigungssystem zu überfordern
die Ukraine hat das Recht sich zu
verteidigen nicht nur das Recht sondern
die Pflicht das mit Waffen zu tun die
nicht schlechter sind als in Russland
die taurusrakete verfügt über taktische
und technische Eigenschaften mit
größerer Reichweite die es uns
ermöglichen wird Ziele in größerer Tiefe
der feindlichen
zu
erichen also der Kanzler er hat also
neben der
Luftabwehr ja ja ich würde das kurz ein
er hat also neben der Luftabwehr die
hier natürlich so dringend gebraucht
wird dringend gefordert war in den
letzten Wochen hat er auch angesprochen
was könnte also z.B der Taurus bringen
über den wir in Deutschland zu häu für
sie auch sehr sehr wichtig so ein System
wie den Taurus zu bekommen warum denn
mit dem Taurus würde man jetzt nicht im
Moment der der Luftabwehr agieren
sondern mit dem Taurus mit dieser
präzisionsrakete würde man also
versuchen Kommandoposten zu treffen man
würde versuchen Munitionslager zu
treffen man würde damit natürlich
versuchen auch Russland zu schwächen und
das würde natürlich dann auch dazu
führen dass im Umkehrschluss es also
auch zu weniger heftigen Luftangriffen
kommen könnte also ja die Ukraine ist
angewiesen auf die Unterstützung des
Westens das ist natürlich ganz Klar
leistet hier also wirklich
Schwerstarbeit und kommt dabei aber eben
auch an ihre Grenzen Raketen müssen
durchgelassen werden da heißt es dann
auch ganz klar die Menschen müssen
einfach Schutz suchen denn man kann wenn
diese massiven Wellen erfolgen einfach
nicht alles vom Himmel holen das geht
nicht und die Situation ist ja so dass
sich Kanzler Scholz weiter gegen die
Lieferung von terorisraketen sperrt gibt
es in der Ukraine dennoch die Hoffnung
dass sich seine Haltung da noch ändern
wird bzw da schließt sich auch eine
Frage aus dem Chat an fühlen sich die
Menschen in der Ukraine sowohl vom
Westen auch ein Stück weit da im Stich
gelassen was man immer wieder hört ist
hier zunächst mal Dankbarkeit dass man
überhaupt natürlich so intensiv
unterstützt wird in den letzten zwei
Jahren also große Dankbarkeit denn ohne
würden die Städte hier ganz anders
aussehen ohne Luftverteidigung ohne
westliche Unterstützung aber natürlich
auch Sorge die spüren wir hier seit bald
vier Wochen ganz massiv Sorge davor was
passiert wenn die westliche
Unterstützung tatsächlich aufhören
könnte was also wenn aus den USA keine
Unterstützung mehr kommt wenn von der EU
diese Hilfen nicht freigegeben werden
wenn also auch unterschiedliche
Waffentypen um die man hier bittet nicht
mehr kommen oder überhaupt gar nicht
erst hier ankommen da gibt es natürlich
die Sorge und einfach auch wirklich die
die große große Hoffnung dass der Westen
einfach weiter unterstützt denn dieser
Krieg das sagen hier uns auch alle
Menschen glauben sie zumindest der ist
noch lange nicht vorbei vielen Dank
Alisa nach Kiev ja und Stichwort
Unterstützung das ist dann auch genau
der richtige Zeitpunkt dass wir
weitergehen nach Brüssel zu unserem
Korrespondenten Ulf Röller hallo
Ulf hallo also in Brüssel ging es heute
um weitere Hilfen eben für die Ukraine
da haben sich Vertreter der natostaaten
und der Ukraine getroffen um sich eben
über diese neuesten Entwicklungen auch
auszutauschen die Forderungen der
Ukrainer sind ja bekannt was ist jetzt
bei diesem Treffen
herausgekommen also muss sag das ist ein
ziemliches Krisentreffen gewesen weil
noch mal in sehr düsteren Farben von
Seiten der Ukraine gezeichnet wurde wie
die Lage ist Alisa hat es ja gesagt es
ist aufgetreten bei dem Treffen der Chef
der Luftwaffe der ukrainischen hat eben
noch mal sehr genau beschrieben wie
diese russischen Angriffswellen aus der
Luft verfolgen und wie sie passieren er
hat gesagt noch hat man sehr hohe
abfangquoten aber die Munition wird
immer weniger und davor hat man echte
Panik auch der Bundeskanzler im Vorfeld
dieses Treffen ganz klar noch mal die
Alarmglocke geschlagen Deutschland sagt
ja selber dass es seine Hilfe für die
Ukraine noch mal um Milliarden erhöht
hat und der Bundeskanzler hat jetzt an
die europäischen Partner appelliert mehr
tun zu müssen in dem Treffen selber gab
es jetzt keine konkreten Zahlen oder
keine konkreten Zusagen Italien und
England hat gesagt in den nächsten
Wochen wird es mehr Waffen für die
Ukraine geben andere haben das in
Aussicht gestellt aber man muss sagen
das läuft doch alles relativ schleppend
und das große Problem ist wohl dass
einmal vielleicht die Depots auch der
natopartner nach diesen zwei Jahren ein
bisschen leer sind und man Angst hat
dass man sich Plank zieht bei den Waffen
und das zweite ist dass die Produktion
von Munition eben nicht einfach so
innerhalb von Wochen sondern Monaten
teilweise von Jahren
dauert und da muss die Rüstungsindustrie
aufgebaut werden und da gibt es ein
strukturelles Problem das Europa hat und
das wird man eben nicht in kurzer Zeit
lösen können
jetzt ist es ja so dass die USA zu den
größten Unterstützern der Ukraine zählen
einige sagen noch denn zurzeit gibt es
einen heftigen politischen Streit
darüber und dann darüber hinaus gibt's
ja auch noch die Sorge dass die Hilfe
dann enden könnte wenn Donald Trump
Präsident würde Ulf du warst auch viele
Jahre Korrespondent in Washington wie
stellt sich die EU auf dieses Szenario
ein also ich glaube dass man sich
eigentlich auch mit Panik darauf
einstellt weil wirklich kann man was
nicht machen wenn die wenn die USA als
hilfslieferant und als als großer
Unterstützer ausfällt kann die EU das
nicht ausfüllen das ist unmöglich und
man muss sehen dass jetzt eben diese 66
Milliarden die Joe Biden der
US-Präsident eigentlich an Ukraine Hilfe
durch den Kongress bringen will damit
werden eben auch viele Waffenlieferungen
gemeint das passiert eben nicht weil das
komplett jetzt in den in den politischen
Streit gekommen ist und man kann aus
Erfahrung sagen jedenfalls weiß ich das
noch von damals wenn jetzt Donald Trump
sich diesem Thema immer mehr annimmt
dann wird das noch mal schwieriger also
ich glaube das ist das ganz ganz große
Problem wie verhält sich die USA und
findet Joe Biden noch eine Möglichkeit
eine Mehrheit innerhalb der Bevölkerung
und vor allem im Kongress zu finden für
die Ukraine Hilfe ich glaube Europa das
hört man bei allen Hintergrundgesprächen
von den verschiedenen Regierungen kann
Amerika nicht ersetzen das ist
schlichtweg unmöglich das wäre wenn
Amerika ausfällt in der ukrainehilfe
eben der absolute Supergau gehen wir
noch mal zurück nach Brüssel da treibt
die EU ja schon neue Milliardenhilfen
voran aber bislang stellt sich ja Ungarn
quer ja um vielleicht ein bisschen was
positives auch hier aus Brüssel zu sagen
weil es ja doch ein sehr düsteres und
dramatisches Bild ist es geht hier um 55
Milliarden Finanzhilfe die die Ukraine
von der EU bekommen soll die Ukraine
braucht dieses Geld spätestens bis ins
Frühjahr weil sie damit mehr oder
weniger ihre laufenden Kosten bezahlt da
geht es Ärzte werden davon bezahlt
Polizisten werden daavon bezahlt die
Verwaltung und Krankenhäuser werden
davon bezahlt und bisher blockiert das
Ungarn es gab heute auch eine Sitzung
hier in Brüssel dazu zum mindestens hat
man gesagt es ist eigentlich sicher dass
man am Gipfel der am 1 Februar
stattfindet und Arn überzeugt bekommt
dass sie doch mitmachen bei diesen
Finanzhilfen und man hat jetzt schon mal
die Verhandlung eingeleitet weil wenn
man diese Hilfen beschlossen hat dann
kommen die nicht gleich man muss do noch
mit dem Parlament mit dem EU-Parlament
verhandeln und das hat man bereits jetzt
schon angefangen in der Hoffnung sich
mit der mit der mit Ungarn zu einigen
letzter Satz vielleicht noch noch mal
positive Botschaft auch wenn Ungarn
diese Hilfe doch bis zum Schluss
boyottieren würde dann sind die 26
Staaten sich einig und sagen und das ist
das Zeichen hier das Signal aus Brüssel
die Ukraine der wird das Geld auf alle
Fälle nicht ausgehen es wird Geld zur
Verfügung gestellt vielen Dank Ulf für
deine Information alles Liebe nach
Brüssel
tschüss und damit gehen wir wieder
zurück zu unserem Militärexperten
Christian
Mölling Herr Ming willkommen zurück wir
haben gerade aus Brüssel gehört neue
Waffen und munitions
gerade eher schwierig und gleichzeitig
hören wir aus Kiev dass die ukrainische
Flugabwehr gezielt Raketen durchlassen
muss wie schätzen Sie die Rolle der USA
ein und die der
Europäer ja ich glaube her röer hat das
eigentlich schon sehr schön die
arbeitsilung beschrieben die Amerikaner
sind
unverzichtbar für die militärischen
Güter weil sie sie einfach herstellen
und in einer viel größeren Zahlen noch
verfügbar haben als die Europäer das
haben die Europäer sind auf der anderen
Seite die EU Europäer auf der anderen
Seite kümmern sich um viel um die Dinge
die das tägliche Leben sicherstellen in
der Ukraine
also alles das was nicht militärisches
dafür sind sie essentiell und wenn einer
dieser Pfeiler wegbricht dann ist das
eine dramatische Situation
ähm es ist gut ein paar farbsprengsel
paar positive Botschaften zu haben aber
insgesamt muss man sagen
laufen wir hier in eine Situation hinein
die sich eigentlich keiner wünschen kann
in Europa
die sehr dramatisch ist für die Ukraine
aber auch für für Gesamteuropa was das
Signal an Russland angeht dass man im
Grunde genommen weiter auf Zeit spielen
kann ja der ukrainische Präsident
selenski hat ja auch heute gesagt also
dass das Zögern des Westens eben Putin
auch stärker machen würde würden Sie dem
zustimmen ja absolut also wir sehen ja
dass Putin im Grunde keine
Verhandlungsbereitschaft hat und er
deutlich nachgelegt hat in den letzten
Wochen
als die die Erfolge auf der einen Seite
an der Front
äh größer geworden sind und auf der
anderen Seite auch er Zuversicht im
Rahmen seiner präsidentschaftsk
Kandidatur ausstrahlen wollte wo hier
klar gemacht worden ist es gibt keinen
Grund zu verhandeln und in der Tat zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt und auch in den
nächsten Wochen und Monaten sehe ich
keinen Grund warum Putin tatsächlich in
Verhandlungen eintreten sollte er kann
abwarten was mit den US-Wahlen passiert
und für ihn wäre ein zu frühes Ende
dieses Krieges auch schlecht weil er
dann tatsächlich sozusagen einen Tag der
Abrechnung haben würde er braucht den
Krieg quasi um am Leben zu bleiben es
ist ein aus Zustand der viel
rechtfertigt und der im Grunde genommen
ihn auch politisch zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt am Leben hält ich würde gern
ein paar Fragen aus dem Chat mit ihnen
durchgehen Amadeus fragt was müsste die
westliche Rüstungsindustrie tun um die
Ukraine in die Lage zu versetzen den
Krieg gewinnen zu können und was werden
die spürbaren Auswirkungen für die
Bevölkerung ja die Rüstungsindustrie
kann erst tätig werden wenn die Staaten
das Geld zur Verfügung stellen und das
ist glaube ich der wichtigste Punkt es
wäre sehr viel mehr möglich ich habe
mich heute heute noch mal intensiv
erkundigt es gibt Kapazitäten die aber
letztendlich nicht abgerufen werden
durch die Europäer durch die Europäische
Union auch nicht oder die Staaten der
Europäischen Union es sind die
Mitgliedstaaten die hier am Drücker sind
die die Möglichkeiten haben wir haben
immer noch Munition die offensichtlich
in hohem Maße ins Ausland geht und nicht
in die Ukraine und auch nicht für die
eigenen Arsenale in Europa genutzt wird
ich glaube hier muss man anfangen
tatsächlich kreativ zu werden auf der
einen Seite nämlich eine Art von
munitionsring Tausch zu machen es gibt
munitionslieferanten die wollen nicht in
die Ukraine liefern die können aber in
nach Europa liefern das heißt hier
könnte man diese Munition aufkaufen und
dann die eigene Munition in die Ukraine
liefern
auf der anderen Seite sehen wir dass die
Frage immer stärker wird ersetzen
möglicherweise kleinsdohnen auch
Artilleriemunition nicht komplett aber
in gewissen Teilen möglicherweise muss
man hier flexibler denken was sozusagen
die Mittel sind die man einsetzt aber
alles das sind tatsächlich
Krisen wahlmöglich
in die man nicht hätte kommen müssen
wenn man frühzeitig gehandelt hätte der
munitionsbedarf war klar dass der kommen
wird und das heißt auch für die Zukunft
ist die Frage das was wir jetzt tun auch
was wir nicht tun wird bestimmen was in
sechs Monaten oder auch in zwei Monaten
in der Ukraine passiert oder auch nicht
passiert das ist ein Teil unserer
Verantwortung denn wir können handeln
und wenn wir es nicht tun dann laden wir
diesen Teil der Verantwortung auf uns es
gibt noch eine weitere Frage kann
Deutschland von den USA Waffen kaufen
und an die Ukraine weitergeen
genau das wäre auch noch eine
Möglichkeit
dass man die USA hat ihre Produktion im
Bereich der der Munition auch der Waffen
teilweise hochgefahren dass man versucht
einen Deal nur mit der Exekutive zu
machen zu sagen nicht die Ukraine kauft
das aber wir kaufen diesesste und geben
Sie dann weiter das ist eine Frage von
Exportkontrolle das wäre möglicherweise
ohne die Involvierung größerer Teile der
des Repräsentantenhaus und des
Kongresses zu machen also wie gesagt das
ist ein Teil der Kreativität da ist
glaube ich zurzeit viel möglich die
Europäer haben sich zum Teil selber
Handschellen angelegt weil sie gesagt
haben europäisches Geld nur für
europäische Rüstungsproduktion
insbesondere Frankreich ist da nach
vorne geprescht ich glaube dass solche
Arten von Rücksichtnahme auf die eigene
Industrie kein Schlüssel dafür ist um
europäische Sicherheit herzustellen denn
darum geht es hier im Grunde genommen
die Ukraine kämpft zur Zeit im Grunde
genommen dafür dass sich Europa und wir
hier zurzeit einigermaßen sicher fühlen
können da kann man glaube ich solche
petit beiseite lassen der grünenpitiker
Anton Hofreiter hat gesagt dass er es
bizarr findet dass der Kanzler bereit
ist Saudi Arabien Kampfjets zu liefern
aber der Ukraine wichtige Waffen
verweigere ist das jetzt Äpfel mit
Birnen verglichen oder hat er da ein
Punkt ja vergleichen kann man alles aber
gleichsetzen nicht ich glaube ich würde
es nicht gleichsetzen die Frage von Taus
aber auch von vielen anderen
Waffensystemen die nicht in der
Öffentlichkeit sind aber die z.B zur
drohnenabwehr genutzt werden Drohnen
sind das kommende Thema so sowohl auf
der ukrainischen als auch auf der
russischen Seite darüber spricht niemand
das ist offentlich zu komplex das sind
alles Dinge die wir hätten schon
anfangen können zu produzieren die wir
vielleicht schneller produzieren können
wenn wir auch unsere eigenen
Vorschriften dementsprechend anpassen da
muss man nicht den Vergleich mit
Saudi-Arabien wagen weil das viel
komplexer ist die Lage damit zu
vergleichen
die Lieferung an die Ukraine sind
sozusagen eine Sache für sich die
unabhängig davon stehen und die
unabhängig davon für die Sicherheit
Europas notwendig sind jetzt soll
Russland ja auch ballistische Raketen
aus nordkoreanischer Produktion
eingesetzt haben könnte das der Anfang
von größeren Waffenlieferungen aus
Nordkorea sein das kann ich nicht
abschätzen aber es zeigt auf einer
anderen Ebene dass Russland eben so
kreativ ist und seine Partnerschaften
nutzt genauso wie die Ukraine das
versucht zu tun und im grundeom sein
schrumpfendes Arsenal nicht
ausschlaggebend dafür ist dass es nicht
mehr kampffähig ist das muss man sich
einfach glaube ich vor Augen für waren
zwei Staaten die tatsächlich einem der
mindestens der eine Staat in einem
existentiellen Kampf sind putin ist für
sich sicherlich auch in einem
existentiellen Kampf das heißt es werden
alle Möglichkeiten genutzt die da sind
und dass jetzt Nordkorea stärker mit
reingezogen wird zumindest als Lieferant
ist
ist nur eine logische Konsequenz daraus
dass Russland eigene Probleme hat in der
Herstellung der Raketen das bedeutet
aber für uns dass man eben nicht
zugucken kann sondern dass man versuchen
muss die Sanktionen immer wieder
nachzuschärfen das ist ein Katz und
Mausspiel das an vielen Fronten abläuft
zu glauben eine Maßnahme würde
ausreichen hat mit einer Realität des
Krieges überhaupt nichts zu tun der sich
ständig weiterentwickelt sven hat auf
Facebook noch mal eine Frage in Bezug zu
den Waffenlieferung aus Nordkorea was
kann denn der Westen tun um die
Unterstützer Russlands also in Klammern
schreibt der China Iran Nordkorea von
Russland abrücken zu lassen ich glaube
dass die überzeugungsmöglichkeiten da
relativ gering sind teil der Regime ist
ja bereits geächtet ähm da kann man
sicherlich hier und da noch mal
versuchen das zu machen ich glaube hier
geht's darum dass wir wir haben direkte
Möglichkeiten der Unterstützung die wir
hochfahren können äh die Möglichkeiten
im Bereich der Munition sind aus meiner
Sicht noch nicht ausgereizt hier es
gibt's noch Möglichkeiten die Frage ist
dann immer ist man bereit das Geld dafür
in die Hand zu nehmen und da sehen wir
natürlich nicht nur in Berlin sondern
auch in anderen Ländern aber gerade auch
in Berlin äh also Thema Notlage und
Schuldenbremse dass wir eben nicht
bereit sind über den Tellerrand unserer
Normallage der letzten Jahre
hinauszugucken und zu verstehen dass wir
es mit dem größten Krieg in Europa seit
70 Jahren zu tun haben und dass er sich
nicht an normale Haushaltsregeln des
Deutschen Bundestages und der
Bundesregierung hält Rom fragt auf
Youtube müsse nicht auch bald mal ein
Umdenken bezüglich militärischer Ziele
in Russland erfolgen die Ukraine muss
sich zerschießen lassen schreibt er und
darf mit gelieferten Waffen sich nicht
wehren
das Umdenken ist wahrscheinlich eher
jetzt nicht nicht für Russland gedacht
sondern für für andere Länder ähm ich
ich kann die oder so würde ich es
interpretieren die Ohnmacht die in der
Frage drinne steht verstehen wir sehen
dass die Realität seit zwei Jahren ist
dass dieses Umdenken hier nicht
stattfindet ähm und das ist sicherlich
sehr traurig weil wir gleichzeitig auch
keine klare Aussage darüber haben was
wir denn tatsächlich erreichen wollen
das fehlt seit zwei Jahren man mauschelt
sich im Grunde genommen so durch wie es
irgendwie geht aber tatsächlich ist der
Preis wir dafür langfristig oder sogar
nur mittelfristig Zahlen tatsächlich ein
höheres Risiko für die Sicherheit in
Europa die Sicherheit nimmt dadurch ab
einfach auch sie hatten es zwischendurch
schon gesagt Putin fühlt sich in seiner
Sichtweise auf den Westen bestärkt dass
er nicht stark handlungsfähig ist und
nicht bereit ist zum in
anführungstrichen Äußersten zu gehen
also die Ukraine mit extremen Maßnahmen
zu unterstützen und das damit eine
Schwäche des Westens zu Tage tritt die
man auch in Zukunft weiter ausnutzen
wird um einfach seine Einfluss wieder
stärker in Richtung Osteuropa
auszudehnen und damit die Europäische
Union und die NATO zu schwächen es gibt
noch eine weitere Frage von Erik wann
werden in großem Umfang Mittel zur
elektronischen Kriegsführung geliefert
und warum wird das bisher nicht gemacht
ähm also man muss fairerweise sagen
einen Teil der Lieferung äh davon
erfahren wir Gott sei Dank nichts aber
Deutschland gehört auch nicht zu den
Ländern das besonders führend ist in all
diesen Bereichen ähm ist die klassische
Bereich der insgesamt im Westen
vernachlässigt worden ist äh ich glaube
die Frage ist eher wann äh schalten wir
um und verstehen dass wir zumindest in
gewissen Teilen in diesem Krieg den wir
zurzeit sehen auch
taktische Formen des Krieges sehen mit
denen wir in Zukunft konfrontiert sein
werden wenn wir sehen dass
offensichtlich drohen die nicht zu uns
gehören über unseren Übungsplätzen
fliegen und wir nicht in der Lage sind
die zu bekämpfen dann ist das in der Tat
ein ohnmachtszeugnis und wenn wir das
hier schon nicht schaffen schaffen un es
in der Ukraine auch nicht insgesamt
sehen wir mit unserer eigenen Sicherheit
ziemlich löcherig aus ähm ich kann nur
sagen ich hoffe dass wir relativ schnell
in diesem Bereich den Hebel umschalten
ähm ob es eine weitere Task Force ist
dazu weiß ich nicht tatsächlich glaube
ich dass die Industrie in der Lage ist
das zu liefern es bleibt dabei ähm
Industrie kann nur dann handeln wenn der
Staat handelt und bereit ist zu handeln
ansonsten ist wieder das Geld da noch
sind die sind die rechtlichen
Rahmenbedingungen dafür geschaffen dass
in Deutschland oder in Europa dazu
gehandelt werden kann es gibt im Chat
auch noch Fragen zur Position Russlands
zur aktuellen Stärke oder eben Schwäche
z.B erkennt man schon an gewissen
Ansätzen dass Russland den Krieg bereits
strategisch verloren hat oder sind
nordkoreanisch nordkoreanische Lieferung
nicht eigentlich ein Zeichen dafür dass
die russische Armee am schwächeln ist
m ich glaube man kann diese Fragen immer
nur sagen für ein gewissen Zeitraum
beantworten oder wir haben im genommen
zwei Zeiträume wir haben Wettlauf so
muss man es glaube ich beschreiben auf
der ukrainischen auf der russischen
Seite nicht nur was den die Front angeht
sondern die Frage wie kriege ich
Material an die Front wie schnell kriege
ich Soldaten ausgebildet alles das was
ich letztendlich zum Kämpfen brauche
verläuft mit unterschiedlichen
Zeitlinien ähm und deswegen geht's auch
dar drum zu welchem Zeitpunkt Dinge zur
Verfügung stehen ähm wenn wir warten mit
der Lieferung von langreichweitigen
Raketen also z.B Taurus bis 2025 2026
dann ist die kerchbrücke möglicherweise
nicht mehr so wichtig dann ist die
Lieferung auch nicht mehr so relevant
das heißt also der Zeitpunkt äh einer
solchen Lieferung von äh von
Waffensystemen kann schon entscheidend
sein dass Russland ähm Anzeichen der
Schwäche zeigt ist das andere Extrem zu
der Diskussion rund um das Pad das wir
jetzt immer wieder so hören beides sind
wie gesagt extreme darauf würde ich mich
nicht verlassen das kann sich das sind
Momentaufnahmen die sich einfach
verändern können Russland ähm hat sich
tatsächlich umgestellt auf diesen Krieg
der Krieg ist etwas was ein wesentlichen
Teil des Staates bestimmt weil es die
Machtstrukturen in Russland tatsächlich
am Leben erhält das kann sich keiner in
diese Machtstrukturen zurzeit leisten
dass dieser Krieg aufhört deswegen gibt
es auch da quasi eine Form von von
Überlebenskampf der ist ganz anders als
der den die Ukraine kämpfen muss
aber es gibt aus beiden sichten heraus
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt keine keine
Position wo man sagen kann wir finden
eine Alternative auch weil man damit
rechnen muss zumindest aus ukrainischer
Sicht das selbst wenn man jetzt sagen
würde wir sind bereit zu verhandeln
Russland erstens ist nicht
verhandlungsbereit und zweitens all das
was bei solchen Verhandlungen rauskäme
wäre wahrscheinlich das Papier nicht
wert auf dass es geschrieben wird weil
Russland ja sich dadurch ausgezeichnet
hat in den letzten Jahren alle alle
Verträge zu brechen die irgendwo
Sicherheit in Europa hergestellt haben
vielleicht noch mal zum Thema
Verhandlungen der italienische
Verteidigungsminister hat heute davon
gesprochen dass jetzt an der Zeit sei
mit Diplomatie den Weg für einen Frieden
zwis zwischen Russland und der Ukraine
zu ebennen es gibt ja auch namenhafte
us-berater die dann schon im Kanzleramt
gehört worden sein sollen die im
endszenario für den Krieg und auch
Verhandlung während des Krieges
gefordert haben wie schätzen Sie das ein
gibt's da eine exit
Option also erstens es gibt ständig
diplomatische Initiativen es gibt auch
Verhandlungen wir haben gesehen dass es
ein großen Gefangenen Austausch gegeben
hat zwischen Russland der Ukraine diese
Verhandlung haben aber Monate gedauert
nur um
Soldaten auszutauschen jetzt muss man
sich vorstellen wie lange das
letztendlich dauern wird hier einen
einen sinnvollen ich will das Wort
Frieden gar nicht in die Hand nehmen
Waffenstillstand auszuhandeln und alles
das was hier an Vorschlägen immer wieder
kursiert kursiert nur unter dem
Vorschlag Verhandlungen verhandeln kann
man die Frage ist ob man ein Ergebnis
fixieren kann und ob irgendjemand glaubt
oder sicherstellen kann dass ein solches
Ergebnis von Verhandlungen auch am
nächsten Tag noch gilt wenn äh es nicht
mehr zum Vorteil Russland insbesondere
ist und ähm diese Frage würde ich zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt mit Nein beantworten
aus der Erfahrung heraus und aus der
Logik heraus dass der Russland zurzeit
handelt ich werde gerne wiederlet aber
ich höre neben den Verhandlungen nichts
wie diese im genommen abgesegnet werden
sollen und erstens das auf der anderen
Seite denn zu Verhandlungen gehören ja
immer zwei dass auf der anderen Seite
überhaupt Russland ernsthaft Platz
nehmen würde und sagen würde ja wir sind
bereit tatsächlich über signifikante
Dinge zu verhandeln die letzten Dinge
die als Vorbedingungen gestellt worden
sind ist im Grunde genommen eine
Abschaffung der ukrainischen Regierung
und Einsetzen eines marionettensystems
eine komplette Entwaffnung der
ukrainischen Armee also im Grunde
genommen die komplette Kapitulation wir
sind zurück zu dem Zeitpunkt wo wir 2022
schon gewesen sind Christian Mölling
viele Fragen beantwortet vielen Dank
dafür für ihre Analyse schönen Abend
noch tschüss se gerne
danke ja und dann danke ich auch euch
für eure ganzen Fragen und Kommentare
das war ZDF heute live und ich wünsche
auch euch noch einen schönen Abend bis
dann
tschüss